مدينه بخموت او ما تبقى منها اكثر من تسعه
اشهر من المعارك دون حسم استعصت المدينه
على الروس الذين لم يتمكنوا من اكماد
السيطره عليها رغم مجهود عسكري مرهق
الان تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها تحقق
اولا انتصاراتها في عمليه الدفاع عن بخموت
قائد القوات الارضيه الاوكرانيه اكد ان
قواته سيطرت على اكثر من عشره مواقع روسيه
في ضواحي بخمت اما روسيا فقد اعلنت ان
اثنين من قادتها العسكريين قتل في معارك
قرب المدينه تبعد بخمه
578 كيلومترا عن العاصمه كييف هي مدينه
صغيره لكنها تحولت الى رمز للصمود بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين ولذلك فاي انتصار فيها قبيل
الهجوم المضاد المتوقع سيعطي دفعه معنويه
كبيره للاوكرانيين
في لندن حيث استقبله رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني حسن الرئيس الاوكراني على
مساعدات بريطانيه جديده ضمنها مئات
الصواريخ الدفاعيه بالاضافه الى طائرات
مسيره يصل مداها الى اكثر من 200 كيلومتر
قبل لندننسكي روما وبرلين وباريس وحصل على
وعود بمساعدات المانيه بثلاثه مليارات
دولار ومساعدات عسكريه فرنسيه وقال ان
اخبارا عن تزويد بلاده بطائره غربيه
متطوره قريبه تبدو هذه الجوده كجزء من
الاستعداد للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي
سيحتاج كثيرا من العتاد